empezamos ahora revista de prensa con
rosa pérez más de burros a usted se
tomaría una cerveza de mantequilla en
dice guys and the wall de harry potter
porque no bueno es un poco raros a
mezclar pero ahora sí vamos a empezar a
hablar y comentando la portada de
liberación de este viernes 3 de
diciembre sobre las elecciones internas
del partido de los republicanos en
francés todo de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales la primera vuelta que se
va a realizar el próximo 10 de abril
rosa el titulares pgex jyoti la
austeridad exacto raúl este bueno
titular en realidad sobra un poco porque
la imagen ya está clarísima la tenemos
aquí y hacer referencia directa a este
cuadro american gothic de gran debut de
principio del siglo pasado que retrata
pues la sociedad estadounidense en este
marco tan conservador y así es como
liberación al fin y al cabo quiere pues
retratar a los candidatos que han pasado
en la primera vuelta de las internas del
partido republicano y que ahora en la
segunda se disputan pues representar a
este partido los republicanos que
recordemos el el del ex presidente
nicolas sarkozy en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2022 y básicamente lo
que destaca la liberación tanto con esta
portada tan clara como dentro de sus
páginas en el editorial es la
derechización
pues si cabe de este partido que ya es
la derecha tradicional francesa y es que
eric ciotti ha sido la gran sorpresa de
esta primera vuelta interna mientras que
valerie pécresse es un poco la favorita
no sin embargo destaca este medio que el
discurso de los republicanos ha estado
muy influenciado por esta
ultraderechista ción que simboliza
también este el candidato que hemos
comentado aquí eric de moore y que ha
forzado y arrastrado a todo el espectro
político francés a debatir sobre la
inmigración la seguridad y tener un
discurso bastante islamófobo podríamos
decir rosa seguimos en europa en este
caso con el fin de una era que llevamos
tiempo también anunciando aquí ayer por
la noche se celebró la especia oficial
de la canciller alemana angela merkel
muy querida aquí nuestra redacción
y raúl para ello hemos querido
seleccionar tres medios de comunicación
tenemos el página 12 de argentina que
titula angela merkel fue despedida con
un tema de nina hagen recordemos esta
figura del punk alemán y es que angela
merkel fue ella misma la encargada de
seleccionar algunos temas que sonaron en
esta despedida militar y de hecho este
tema punk que a merkel le recuerda a su
juventud en alemania del este fue
interpretado como los otros como las
otras piezas musicales por el ejército
alemán y también hemos destacado la bbc-
que dice angela merkel el emotivo
discurso de la canciller alemana y la
canción punk que sonó en su despedida
otra vez y en este discurso la canciller
que ya la semana que viene pues la deja
a su supuesto en funciones destacó pues
la importancia de creer en la ciencia y
en los hechos no en referencia a esta
pandemia que nos ha tocado vivir y ella
por último la deutsche welle este medio
alemán destaca en su despedida con
honores militares piden defender la
democracia y es que hay un punto a
destacar y es que angela merkel
invito a representantes de todos los
partidos excepto de la extrema derecha
alternativa por alemania imagen usted a
la saliente canciller angela merkel
bailando pongo rosa pues tenemos un
pasado en aragón vamos a cambiar de tema
os un artículo de el salto rosa porque
dice que sara la empresa es señalada
como una de las responsables de la
deforestación de la amazonía exacto
porque esta semana se ha hablado mucho
de zahara y del grupo inditex en general
porque se ha conocido definitivamente
que marta ortega la hija del propietario
amancio ortega va a las riendas de
la empresa definitivamente en 2022 pero
esta semana también se ha publicado un
informe redactado por slow factory que
señala a sara como una de las empresas
responsables de forma aunque sea directo
o indirecta de la deforestación ante la
amazonía y es que de hecho para obtener
las pieles inditex y que recordemos es
la empresa matriz que tiene estar así
como para un pull and bear bershka
massimo dutti y otras marcas para
obtener las pieles para sus tejidos pues
las compras a los grupos gbs y tipos a
que son principales responsables de la
extensión de la ganadería pues en la
cuenca del amazonas y otras compañías
que también aparecen en el informe muy
conocidas como adidas nike new balance o
la costa rosa y seguimos en américa
latina con ojo crítico este medio de
investigación peruano que titula
militares en retiro con discursos
extremistas se vinculan a políticos para
apoyar la vacancia esto es un artículo
de ernesto cabral exacto es una
investigación pues que señala qué
influencia qué papel están teniendo pues
los grupos ultraderechistas en perú en
términos de desestabilizar un poco pues
en el ámbito político dice como en otros
países donde están surgiendo grupos
extremistas en perú algunos militares en
retiro del ejército la marina y la
fuerza aérea han aparecido en la escena
política para sumarse a los partidos de
la derecha más conservadora que piden la
nulidad de las elecciones y apoyan la
destitución del presidente castillo
señala como estos grupos tienen un
discurso agresivo invocan a la violencia
e incluso en algunos casos al golpe y
también señala como partidos como fuerza
popular recordemos de keiko fujimori
pues están interesados un poco en
empoderar a estas agrupaciones dice con
el fin de demostrar que las calles
también quieren la salida del mandatario
y de esta manera favorecer el discurso
que ellos pues se promueven en el
congreso rosa gracias por toda la
información entonces nos vemos el lunes
con más revista de prensa feliz fin de
semana y ya vamos a pasar a conversar
con nuestro primer invitado al día